a story in five words
story in five words brain scan reads
your thoughts judge the University of
Texas scientists created a program that
can read someone's brain waves in an MRI
machine and accurately created AI
generated readout of their thoughts and
they say it could one day help people
who can't speak but you know why this is
important right do you know why why it's
not you don't want to hear what other
people are thinking you want to know
what your dog's thinking well yeah but
you know I do want to know what my dogs
plural three of them what if their dog
said I hate pink
well then I wouldn't die in pink anymore
she dies her dog's pink no one dog the
white dog okay yeah yeah
I wanna I would like to see that yeah
um no here's the problem they can I
think they think they can predict
whether or not you're going to commit a
crime oh and whether or not there was a
movie about this about 20 years ago that
that preemptively can tell if you are
you know of the kind of mentality that
you will try to do you like that love it
oh good for you lock them up before they
commit to Crime that's right lock them
up before they're born that's what I say
yeah read their little fetal brain scans
lock them up I know I'm kidding yeah and
it's are you worried about AI I mean
just think about this that is going to
lead into a lot of divorce a lot of
breakups I mean think about if you are
bad people your older girlfriend is
going to ask who did you yeah where were
you or like where were you do you like
my hair yeah do I gain weight yes you
know what I mean yeah you're like this
is going to be so dangerous do you know
what's funny though you just reminded me
that women think that they already read
your mind right yeah it's like you know
I didn't think that and they go yeah
what are you rolling your eyes for you
know I'm skipping you going to Tyrus
instead okay what do you think cat
I'm so Tyrus I'm so glad you asked it's
great to have you back I need some
stability around yeah I well I think
that whoever agreed to do this study is
boring because you're not you let
everybody see everything in your head
how boring are you yeah if I did this
I'd be like okay don't think about
that stuff yes thereby revealing that
stuff that I don't want people to know
about who would let people do this
listen this is stupid
stupid we already have this it's called
a face yeah okay you sit there she looks
she knows you're not thinking about her
she knows she knows Chopin your Escape
she doesn't need some AI just a stare
okay everything you described is what we
go through every day already so we're
looking into a scan it's not going to
help you this is not going to read it
right anyways because she's going to
pre-determine you doing something wrong
anyways so we don't have to worry about
this there's no AI just hide your face
like the rest of us so you know they say
that
do you know you should always talk to
your wife with her back to her good idea
right oh yeah like that's not fair
because you can just look over the top
of you
or you know what remember that you saw
that guy he was like a soldier that he
had eyeballs tattooed on his eyelids so
he could sleep and he just had his eyes
open the whole time it's another little
trick you can do with your your spouse
so you can sleep while she's talking to
you or you can just break up
that's a lot of work yeah yeah all right
it is expensive thanks judge she doesn't
know anything but the judge knows a lot
yeah I'm gonna end up sleeping on a
cotton Air Force One
we gotta move on hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else